Nothing can break the bond between one of
Game of Thrones' most memorable couples.
Jason Momoa, who played Khal Drogo on the
first season of the HBO fantasy drama, got
emotional when discussing his on-screen wife
Emilia Clarke's health battle that almost
took her life… twice.
The Daenerys Targaryen actress revealed earlier
this year that she had previously suffered
two brain aneurysms, the first of which came
in 2011, just as Game of Thrones was taking
off.
Speaking with ET at the Game of Thrones Season
8 premiere in April, Momoa praised Clarke's
courage and tenacity during the hardest time
in her life.
"It's very sad, because we almost lost her
numerous times.
So, I love her to bits and she's here and
she's going to do great things with it and
teach the world."
In March of 2019, Clarke penned a moving essay
for the New Yorker in which she detailed that
she had experienced a brain aneurysm at the
age of 24, and then was stuck with a brain
bleed two years later while doctors attempted
to reduce the size of the original aneurysm.
The actress opened up about the emergency
surgery she underwent to seal off the aneurysm.
Clarke then detailed the second operation
required to "take care of" the expanding growth
in her brain plus the subsequent surgery needed
when that operation failed and left her with
a "massive bleed."
She wrote,
Of her second and third surgeries, she wrote,
In the midst of all this hardship and a double-brush
with death, Clarke was actively filming Game
of Thrones, as well as rehearsing for the
2013 Broadway rendition of Breakfast at Tiffany's.
Though she kept her composure, told virtually
no one about what she had been through, and
even denied the genuinely accurate reports
that she had experienced life-threatening
trauma, Clarke was overwhelmed with exhaustion
and anxiety.
She wrote,
But, like the fireproof Mother of Dragons
she plays, Clarke was resilient and determined,
and came out on the other side with a renewed
sense of hope and purpose.
After bravely sharing her story with the public,
Clarke announced that she had partnered with
executives in the United States and the United
Kingdom to develop a charity called SameYou,
which works to provide additional and more
immediate rehabilitation options for young
people who have suffered brain injuries, as
well as to fund research, advocate for policy
change, and "facilitate innovations in specialist
nurse training."
"She's so brave, in helping the world and
trying to raise awareness."
Six seasons later, Clarke says she couldn't
be more grateful to have "cheated death twice"
and lived to help bring Game of Thrones to
its epic conclusion.
She wrote,
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.